[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Giving back gave me an
opportunity that cannot be
repaid for.
It's only right that I want to
do the same thing for somebody
else.
Basically, the
next generation is
going through a smoother
experience, a faster growth.
- The Boston Celtics
select Guerschon Yabusele.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BABACAR SY: OK, this
is a quick recap here
of what we've done
the last 20 years.
And as Bill said, it's
been quite a journey.
It started 20 years ago with
a dramatic event in my family,
where my sister, who was 22
years old at the time, died.
And she passed
away in conditions
that were pretty tough
because her heart failed,
and she was pretty upset at
what was going on in the world.
And she was trying
to make a difference.
So a couple of weeks later,
we discovered her writings
that she had left behind.
And there was a
project there that
was basically encouraging people
to invest in other people.
And I took this project
and I implemented
what was my passion,
at the time,
was basketball into the project
and founded Giving Back,
with a motto that
was my mom's motto.
Every time I was going
through the front door,
she kept saying, never
forget where you come from.
And that started a whole
movement, a global movement,
which I went on and try to help
kids from all around the world
to get scholarships
through sports, basketball,
and education, and to also have
the moral contract that they
will never forget
where they come from,
and they will come back to
their communities at some point
and give back.
And so that led me here
in the United States,
in the beautiful
city of Newark, New
Jersey, where we set up the
first basketball camps there.
And whatever we call
social business now,
we were doing at
the time already.
And it gave a lot of exposure
to these kids and some of them
are here right now.
And it gave them a
lot of opportunities
to go through their studies
and go through a different path
than what they were
supposed to be.
So these kids came
from France, but also
Senegal, Mali,
Burkina Faso, Niger,
a little bit of everywhere.
And we later set up
academies in Africa
of sports leadership and social
leadership at the same time.
The whole story here is really
about the power of giving back.
We think that giving
is a wonderful act.
It is an amazing act.
And we just feel that
it's not a complete act.
When you give, you
fix situations,
and you probably heal
and put a Band-Aid.
But we think that with
the act of giving back,
we can really put the
person into a position
to come back and
empower other people
and keep the chain alive.
And that's really our
sustainable way for us
to build any social business.
And we never
received any grants.
And we were able to put
this all together because we
have our alumni that
came back to the program
and were able to help.
So some of them are here.
And I'm going to invite
Kudjo Sogadzi here,
who was one of the
first student athletes
to come to the United States,
and had quite a journey
coming from some of the
toughest areas in France
and going all the way and
working to Wall Street.
Kudjo.
KUDJO SOGADZI: Thanks, Babacar.
Thanks for allowing
us to be here today.
It's a pleasure for us,
all of us, to be at Google
and to share our stories.
And for being part of
the Giving Back group
program is a privilege, Babacar.
As Babacar said, I'm from Paris.
I came to the States
about 20 years ago.
Actually, Babacar recruited
me to play basketball
from the streets of
Paris and to allow
me to come here to the
States and play high school
basketball.
And from high school, I ended up
going to college for four years
and playing Division
1 at Fairfield.
I've been very, very
fortunate because I'm
coming from a very tough
area outside of Paris.
It's a small town.
It was majority low income and
minority groups and families.
And before I came to
the States, education
was never a big part
of what I believed in.
I think you've always
been in a class
where there's an athlete
who doesn't work and doesn't
do his homework.
Well, that was me.
I've always been the one
to put school to the side.
But coming to the States has
allowed me to disregard that
and to focus on
education and understand
the value of education.
I was fortunate enough
to get a four-year degree
at a school in Connecticut.
From there, I tried to play
overseas, in France, actually,
professionally.
It didn't work out.
I came back to the States,
went back to New York City,
and worked at a hedge fund.
And I was there for eight years.
In the meantime,
I received an MBA.
So I was going to school
part-time, went to school
while I was working.
And now, I'm actually
studying for the LSAT
to go to law school.
And what Babacar
mentioned earlier
is that it's one
thing about education,
it's something that you can
carry with you all the time
and no one can
take away from you.
And yes, my dream ultimately
was to come to the States
and play in the NBA.
But things happened,
and I wasn't unable to.
But I was able to take on
the next step of my life
and do something else through
education and through work.
And my journey is
not over, obviously.
I'm even looking to
go to law school.
I'll graduate-- I'll
be 40 years old.
I'll be the oldest law
student in the school I go to.
But I think one of the
things that Nelson Mandela
said, the quote is, "Education
is the most powerful weapon
for change."
And I think this is what we
are trying to provide here
at Giving Back is to give hope
to people that, whether it's
through sports or
through education,
they can make something
out of themselves,
and they can change the world.
And what I want to do, and
what we're trying to do,
is to change people's lives.
And I want to be a role model
for them from my standpoint,
so yeah.
BABACAR SY: Thank you, Kudjo.
Kudjo is one of the
hundreds of kids
that received a scholarship
to come to the United States
and took advantage of it.
We have had a lot of
basketball success stories,
but his story is one of the
biggest success stories of all
because he was able to
capitalize on the education
and be who he is right now.
So that's also
something that we always
try to push is to understand
that the more we're
going to empower
people with education,
then the more they will be
inclined to also give back,
and to know how to give
back to their communities.
And in that regard, I'm going
to introduce Guerschon Yabusele
from the Boston
Celtics, who also
has a pretty unbelievable
path that led him
not only to the
NBA, but also to be
our president for the
organization here,
and be a social leader.
Guerschon, it's yours.
GUERSCHON YABUSELE:
So first of all, I
want to say thank you
for having us today.
It's really important
for us and means a lot.
So my name is
Guerschon Yabusele.
I'm a Boston Celtics player,
the best team of the NBA,
obviously.
But today, I really try to
share part of my story with you.
So I grew up in France, a
little city in nearby Paris.
I always been playing
basketball there,
and then moved to
a [INAUDIBLE] city
in France to play basketball.
And me, in every
team that I play,
I never been the best
player of my team.
I've been underestimated
all of my career.
But one day, Babacar
gave me a call,
and he and the association
really believed in me
and helped me
through my process.
Since this day, we always been
on the phone, always talking.
And then one day, I had
the chance to go to LA
and play against the best
players in the country.
And this experience for me has
been a big, big, big part of me
being here today because I
had to play against the best
player, understand how
life is, and understand
the change that I got
to play basketball,
and it was really good for me.
So as soon as I get
back from this trip,
everything changed in my life.
I just understand
the things more.
I was thankful for everything.
And since this
day, Babacar and me
had a great contact,
because I'm from France.
And where I grew up, I
grew up in a big family.
Sometimes we had less, so it
was really difficult for me.
I grew up with
some of my friends.
They failed.
Some of them went to jail.
So for me, at this
point, being thankful.
It was just something
that I was dreaming,
but something that I had
in my head every day.
It just started being
a mission for me.
And helping the people give back
to the communities means a lot.
And this project for us
is really something big
with the young talented ladies.
Amsatou's going to explain
us a little bit more
about her story, but the project
really means a lot for us.
Like I said, the mission is in
our head, but also in our life.
That's why we're going
through everything.
My dream came true
in coming to the NBA.
This association did a lot
for me, for me and my family.
And today, I can really say
that basketball saved my life,
helped me through everything.
And I'm really
thankful for that.
Thank you.
BABACAR SY: Thank
you, Guerschon.
As you see, Guerschon
and Kudjo here
represent well the
ecosystem of giving back as
far as the young
student athletes
that were empowered
through their endeavors
and that also were able to
overcome their own problems.
And we see a lot of problems
all around the world.
And we think it's always
with the powerful that
has to come back,
come to the powerless,
and find the solutions.
But we know that in those
rough neighborhoods,
there's a lot of kids that
have a lot of talents.
And if they're given a chance
to bring their talent up
in whatever it is, they
can change the world
because they can grow
up with that mission
to come back to the
communities and change it.
As Guerschon
mentioned, right now,
we're trying to scale the
system, this Giving Back
system.
And the best way
that we found is
to put our efforts
into young women,
especially young women
right now in West Africa.
And I'm going to introduce
a video right now
that's going to tell you the
story of Amsatou Diop, who
is right here, and who's
part of our program now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMSATOU DIOP (VOICEOVER):
Growing up in Italy,
I understood the
word "privilege" when
spending summertime in my
beautiful native Senegal,
and seeing a lot
of my girl peers
having no access to
education and no skill
that will allow them to
enjoy a dignified basic life.
[? Micah ?] [? Zimbita ?] is
one of the seven million women
whose social fate is doomed
to fail before their life even
start.
I had to find a way
to break this cycle.
Privilege was all I had,
a scholastic education,
access to global
culture and thinking,
and more importantly, a loving
and caring single mother
that gave me more
than I ever needed.
I realized how much some of our
dysfunctional local resources
had to offer.
I went on collecting
and recycling
the small wasted
piece of African craft
that our 100,000
worker [? bearers ?]
throw away everyday.
And I created a
sustainable interior design
brand named Wolof.
[AFRICAN MUSIC PLAYING]
The Wolof solution is accessible
by any girl who is a willing
learner, as all
it takes is $0.20,
the cost of a
thread and a needle,
to come and acquire the basics
of my free-of-charge workshops,
open to young girls that
have no access to education.
My vision is to sell
Wolof globally and disrupt
the interior design
industry by giving
a voice to the voiceless, and
yet so elegant and powerful
women of Africa.
Soon enough, Wolof will
be able to tell the world
a new set of inspiring tales
of the hard-working, resilient,
creative, and traditional
African women.
This community will keep growing
as the girls we empower today
will mentor the next generation
of interior designers.
They will be able to enjoy
a sustainable living,
break the cycle of
illiteracy, and will
become role models
of their daughters,
just like my mother has
been for me all my life.
[AFRICAN MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BABACAR SY: Amsatou.
AMSATOU DIOP: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for
having us here today.
As you saw, I am the
proud founder of Wolof,
but also I am the mentor
of the Grow Academy, one
of the first mentors.
So I have been on the program
for the past few months.
And for those past
few months, there
have been two words
that have stuck with me
and have been my mantra.
So those two words are
"embrace yourself."
A lot of people ask me why
I choose those two words
because they've also
been my Instagram
hashtag for every
feature that I've posted.
But those two words because
for the past few months,
I have been embracing every
single fiber of myself.
I've been embracing my fears,
my flaws, my weaknesses.
But mostly, I've been aware
of what is surrounding me.
And as a mentor for the next
generation of the Grow Academy,
I want to pass all this
feeling to these girls
because I want them to be
fearless, to be powerful,
but mostly, I want them
to believe in themselves.
Because we live in a society
where everything they tell us
everyday is, you can't make it.
And my question is always, why?
It's because you are a woman.
I want them to actually
believe that they can if they
put their mindset into it.
That's why I created
the Grow Academy.
And it's not like
any other academy
because we use tools as virtual
reality, video games, chess,
coding, programming, boxing
because we want these girls
to be challenged everyday.
And we want them to
believe that if you
put your mindset into
something, you can make it.
You have to break all the
obstacles that are in your way
in order to do that.
And as you know,
the Grow Academy
is going to use the same
ecosystem as Giving Back,
meaning that the girls
that we empower today
will come back as a mentors
for the next generation.
But we're not like the men here.
It's not going to take
us 10 years to do that.
It can take us--
we want these girls
to be able to do that
within three months.
And having done this program
for a week before coming here,
I can assure you
that these girls are
able to give back within weeks.
Within a week, they
are able to teach
others what they've learned.
Within a week, they appropriated
the program for themselves.
And for me, that
is that incredible
because I now can
see all the work that
has been done by
Giving Back and by Grow
now, that actually
it's possible.
Because some of them, we
went to the Giving Back day,
where they taught all
of these girls that
don't have access to education
how to play video games.
And those girls, that same
day, were able to help others--
the other girls that are
there how to play video games.
And they've never
been to school.
They don't know what is football
or how to play with cards.
So I can assure you that
this program is amazing,
and I'm really thankful
to be here today
and to speak for these
girls, and also to speak
for myself, for my story,
and also for Giving
Back and the Grow Academy.
Thank you.
BABACAR SY: Thank you, Amsatou.
We actually have a little
video about the Grow Academy,
where you're going to see
those girls in action.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[GENTLE PIANO MUSIC]
- I wanted to use my passion,
and my passion is fashion,
to give people happiness.
It turned out, as
I am now a member
of the next generation
of the Grow Academy,
something caught me.
It was the motto of Giving Back.
It was never forget
where you come from.
[APPLAUSE]
- That's how Grow also has
been on the transmission
and the reinvesting
in the program.
We decided to focus
on women because we
know that women are the future.
- When one advances,
we all advance.
When one succeeds or knows
how to solve a problem,
we help to bring the other
girl up along with her.
Nobody gets left behind
in the Grow Academy.
- In the Grow Academy, not
only do we believe in you,
but we want you to also
believe in yourself.
It's never easy.
It's never going to
be an easy journey.
Sometimes you'll fall.
Sometimes you'll feel
so good about yourself,
and sometimes it will
knock you right back down.
But the point of it all is that
you get up, brush off the dirt,
and then get back right on it.
And you don't become champions,
you become who we truly are.
- [SHOUTING]
- On the first move,
you move two spaces.
[LAUGHTER]
- [COACHING]
- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
- Very, very simple English, OK?
Good morning.
- Good morning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BABACAR SY: OK, so
this was the last video
here that we're going to show.
But before we go for the
Q&A, just this experience
with the Grow Academy
has been transforming
the whole organization,
really, because we
came to the realization
that in order
to be able to get powerful
social entrepreneurs,
it's not just about going
onto a path, a set path,
like, hey, here's your
mission, your vision.
Here is what you've got to do.
But it's also about
revealing the best in us,
whether it's the
self-confidence, the ability
to transmit the messages to the
next generation, the ability
to listen, to have
collaborative work.
So that's what these
girls have been doing.
And Amsatou has been a terrific
mentor for all those girls.
And all those girls
that you see here
are going to be the mentor to
the next generation as well.
And that's how we are
building this community.
And we think that if
every community can
be built that way,
every social business
can be built that way,
then that's the answer
to be sustainable and
to be able to defeat
the problems of poverty.
So thank you
everybody for coming.
Thank you for having
us, again, Google.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: I just wanted to ask
a couple questions to wrap up
here.
First, you mentioned
Giving Back Days.
Do you want to explain
to us a little bit more
about how they work
and what your plans are
for the future for that?
BABACAR SY: So the Giving Back
Days are days of happiness
that we give to kids,
usually, or people
from vulnerable groups.
And what we want
in those days is
to be able to reproduce what
we do at the Grow Academy,
meaning really give
them confidence
into what they are doing
and show them the path
of giving back, in one day.
And we do that in a fun way.
But also, it's a
platform for all of us
to be able to go back and give.
And that's one thing that is
very important in our system is
that ecosystem that we put
together, where everybody can
come in and be a part of it.
And so that's the
Giving Back Days.
And it's been very
successful because we've
been able to touch a
lot of young people
through that program.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Babacar.
Next, for those of us
in the audience that
would like to get involved,
what are some of the ways
that we could help out
Giving Back and Grow Academy?
BABACAR SY: Well, come.
Come over to Senegal.
You'll see.
It's a beautiful country.
It's sunny.
And more importantly,
those girls
can really benefit from the
experiences of everybody.
Again, we talk about mentorship.
There's no professors.
There's no traditional
teacher in our academy.
And these are college girls.
But I think they really enjoy
having expertise and experience
from all over the world.
So that will be the first thing.
The other thing is
that we're always
trying to research new
ways to problem solve.
You saw that lab
that we put together
with all those different tools.
And if you have any ideas, if
you want to be part of that,
please let us know.
And the last thing is that
those girls, they put together
all their work, they organized
their work into Google Drive--
Google Docs-- and they share it.
So they have self-evaluation
within themselves,
but also, we invite anybody
that would want to be a mentor
and not being able to
come all the way there
to also be able to do it that
way so that a girl could share,
for example, her work with you.
SPEAKER: Well, on
behalf of Google,
thank you very much for
coming, Babacar, Guerschon,
Amsatou, and Kudjo.
We really enjoyed
hearing from you
and appreciate the
great work that you're
doing for your communities.
BABACAR SY: Thank you very much.
KUDJO SOGADZI: Thank you.
AMSATOU DIOP: Thank you.
BABACAR SY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]